were privileged as always to have the
Ukrainian ambassador to the UK for
starkov here in the studio with us good
morning thank you for joining us on the
program this morning what's the
situation in Kiev at the moment
we have conversations at a very high
level that we will have to deal with at
least 4.5 people without the hit and
without electricity somebody is even
talking about evocating the whole
capital of Ukraine how do you start to
evacuate a whole city as has been
suggested by the mayor if that if is
necessary where do they go I hope it
won't come to this and we're still sort
of trying to renew all the electric
facilities generating stations the
Transformations all of it if it come to
it we'll have to move them back to west
west of Ukraine live and all the places
closer to the European Union is it a
possibility
that's a huge number of people to to be
evocated but Ukrainian Winters can
become quite harsh we have to think how
we do it
Russia continuing to hit your energy
supplies we fight back we managed to to
take from the sky around 70 75 percent
of all the drones and Rockets the
Iranian of the Rockets does for sure
today they flee the Russian Fleet did
not did not leave the basis for the EC
where they launched their rockets at us
but this bloody the Iranian drones this
is the biggest problem the chip the
number they come in the Swarm very
difficult to deal with Iranians are
involved with that I believe yes that's
their doing although they are telling us
not and they even sending the notes to
All the embassies here in London that's
Ukraine is a line but we have so many of
them already been taken so we can check
what the Iranians are saying is that
they did provide drones but it was
before the war
at the same time you know we have
evidence that thousands and thousands of
them been provided and some of them
store it now in Belarus which is on top
on north of Ukraine quite closer to Kiev
City for example
can the West do to help try to protect
your skies first of all we have to do
what we started with even we talked with
you all this the beginning of the year
that we have to cover the skies free
Ukraine it means sometimes planes in
most of the cases Rockets anti-air we
can also think of of some creative ideas
but Warehouse I have to increase
pressure on Russia and Iran as well in
what way it was around political
sanctions more or less the same with
Russia just to keep them under pressure
until they will won't be able anymore to
send any Rockets to know to build new
what they're trying to do now they're
trying to start producing them
especially these cheap ones the the
Iranian ones
separates here I believe the power
station is now back online uh what
difference will that make
this this particular station is
responsible the biggest in Europe as
nuclear biggest in Europe so it's
responsible for quite a large number but
in most of the cases not generation the
problem because we already have almost
10 million people left houses that are
not using the electricity
and the economy is not running on the
full years you can imagine so we have at
least
twice as less in consumption the problem
with with the transmission was with the
wires was was just the equipment
what would you say I was chatting to
Mary Robinson former Irish president now
chair of the elders when it comes to
cop27 and she's heading to charmel
Sheikh next week as we know our own
prime minister and many other leaders
are there at the moment she was making
the point that because of the situation
in Ukraine we are behind where we need
to be when it comes to the climate
crisis uh what would you say in response
it is also true but we've seen pictures
like Russian tanks are going over the
solar stations just just to break them
to somebody else on some business
stations so that's that nothing can be
done if somebody is deliberately trying
to destroy your nation or your economy
it's not like you move to the to the
mill so we're at and all solar stations
you have to have peace that's what we're
trying to achieve you know in our case
this system was built that we have
central heat generation which is much
cheaper from point of view economy is
much better but then when you hit the
Central Station so many districts around
it uh lacking the Heat hour I was
reading about the grain situation we had
thought that that had been fixed and
there had been an agreement so that
Odessa the ships could come in and out
of getting the grain around the world I
believe that that's not necessarily the
case anymore Russians promise or the
threatened rather that they will get out
of the deal but uh very likely to have a
turkey on on board so Turks and U.N told
that we're still in in the process we
will be doing it so Russians had to
change their minds and get back to the
to the treaty again so we are exporting
in short
talk to me about the situation for so
many people in Ukraine they must be War
Weary by now how are they coping they're
very at the same time they they're quite
sediments and your example of of Great
Britain at the second world war is
showing that you can't intimidate the
government by going with terrorist
attacks against the the population we
are suffering but people are quite quiet
quite strongly
you know directing asset supporting the
president supporting the Armed Forces to
fight it is not working for Russians
what should your president what more can
your president do to try to bring this
war to a conclusion uh people starting
to talk about negotiations and we we
agree to negotiate if only we can have
Russians out of our lands that's the
starting point for negotiations we'll
have to negotiate many things how we
live with them for these generations and
generations and generations now when
they're killing our people who had to
get them out and understand how they
will be repairing the everything they've
done to us or the reparations sanctions
and everything this is lots and lots of
things to negotiate
some suggestions that the U.S midterm
elections which are tomorrow once those
are over we may see some movements as
far as a resolution in Ukraine is
concerned do you think that's a
possibility if United States will be
able to provide us with more weapons and
you know the issues that they are
providing a lot they're providing bulk
most of it second is UK so the all the
nations can actually Step Up in doing so
if we are to provide Ukraine over the
year or something when they supported
the political support the people support
can diminish what we're asking right now
to give this this equipment now so we
can end up this war much much sooner and
we are quite successful look at it the
her zone is about to be freed that's the
only more or less considerable City the
Russians managed to get final thought
from you this area if I may when I
interviewed our prime minister our
present prime minister earlier on in the
summer and he said that his first
overseas trip would be to Ukraine that
obviously hasn't happened because he's
gone to charm milkshake are you still
expecting him absolutely well are not
going to discuss the dates because of
the security of your prime minister but
he is coming to Ukraine quite soon he's
coming quite soon yes okay it's good to
talk to you thank you very much for
joining us